foreign
was kidnapped mutilated and murdered
Irvin and lovewood tries to attack the
man accused of killing his child as he
appears in court for the first time
later outside his home Irvin tries to
make sense of all that's happened I lost
my father almost in the similar Manor my
father was married 18 years ago there's
moments where I just cry you know over
what happened to my dad and now I have a
daughter who gets mad at as well you
know so I don't think this is something
that one can recover from what Harbor
was taken from a park near her home
lured by the promise of sweet
in the CCTV footage bohrabo was last
seen alive with her alleged killer
the next morning around 9 11 she's found
no traces of blood she's chopped her
hair is cut
she's she doesn't have eyes she's burnt
like I want to understand where this
happened you know but then the police
the police are too not finding answers
parts of a body were found in Shallow
Graves nearby but other parts of
bohabo's body are missing behind me
people are looking for them but they've
found another body this time in adult
male it appears the body was burnt
before being thrown into the water
people here are angry
[Applause]
as police arrived nearly an hour after
that body was found they're chased Away
by local people who say they've had
enough of perpetrators freely carrying
out crimes they killed people for money
they killed kids for money they rape
people here they dump them here in this
dump but the police are not doing
nothing they just pass and look and pass
549 children were killed in South Africa
in the first six months of this year
that's an average of about three a day
some of the children will know more than
a year old
for many fear and frustration are
growing for bugabo's mother so are anger
and anguish
she was so full of life you know
was so full of life
Al Jazeera Johannesburg